time for don't buy it diy it
our next guests are a diy duo who have
more than
2 million followers on youtube
alone they have even more on other
platforms and they're all about
easy projects that won't break the bank
and they're about to show us
one now in honor of our diy week please
welcome
kelsey mcdermott and becky wright
also known as the sorry girls
hi thanks for having us thank you so
much
so excited joining us today now quick
question
you're named the sorry girls you're from
canada
and is it because people say sorry in
canada
a certain way yeah you got it that's
pretty much it as well
as well as the fact that um when we
started our youtube channel we didn't
know what it was going to be about
but we knew we were canadian and that
wouldn't change
well i love it okay so you guys have
another series that i'm obsessed with
because it's called
that cost how much
that pitch in my head and i'm so
appreciative that you guys
have this show called that it's i think
what is coming out of
most of our mouths when we do look at
the price tag so you're gonna diy
something that's normally really
expensive in stores
becky what are we diying today today i'm
gonna show you how you can diy
your own stone ceramic inspired lamps
the best thing about this is that you
can do it with a lamp that you already
have that you don't love anymore or
maybe one from the thrift store
we're also going to be diying the
lampshade too which is a scandinavian
inspired
inspired trend that's coming back and
lands like these can cost over 200
so we're gonna do it for a lot less
today all right
walk me through this okay so first off
for the base
we have some regular old house paint
here
and we're going to add in a couple
tablespoons
of our baking powder this is going to
give us
texture lots of texture and then start
mixing it it'll slowly start
um making like a mousse texture that's
what we're looking for here
i love that if it was a different color
we'd kind of want to eat it but we're
not going to
don't if it was pink it would look like
cotton candy
i was thinking like more chocolate
chocolate for sure
oh yeah i might have eaten a chocolate
cupcake over
my sink last night
one of those nights okay
are you getting the texture oh wow you
guys this is amazing
i've never seen anything like it it's
like moose once we have some of our
textured paint we're just going to go
ahead and put it on our base here
we're going to want to go the same
direction because you know think if
we're trying to replicate
some natural stone pottery we want
um to kind of go the same direction so
i'm just going horizontally
across the base and don't smooth it out
too much because we want that texture to
really come through
and when it's all done and dried it's
going to look
something like this the texture showing
through and looks a lot more expensive
now i think
all right becky is going to show us how
to do the lampshade to finish it all off
all right so what we've already done for
the shade is actually taking apart the
one that came with the lamp we've
deconstructed it
taken the fabric off so we have the
rings
left and we're going to be making a new
shade entirely for this
okay so to make this we're doing it out
of cardstock
this is eight and a half by eleven and
we're going to start by just folding
accordion style
about three quarters of an inch are you
with me drew
i am very with you okay we we are
repeating this process
a lot of times until we have a long
sheet that looks like this
our aim is to get a piece of accordion
style paper that's about twice
the circumference of the shade that
we're going for
and how do you adhere the pieces
together may i
ask you can just use
plain clear tape because we don't want
to see it so any
simple craft tape will do the job just
tape all your pieces together until you
have a long accordion piece like so
so there's one more step we need to do
before we can attach it to the shade and
this is really simple it requires
using a hole punch to punch a series of
holes along the top and the bottom of
the shade
and you'll also want to do a little slit
with some scissors so that we can access
the hole punches okay
and this is what's going to let us clip
our shade onto the rings this part is
so simple it's amazing
so all you need to do is take your ring
and then with the holes that we've made
just
go ahead and clip them right onto the
ring all the way around in a circle
okay got it are we are you um now
clipping on your shade to your ring
oh you wouldn't believe it i'm so
amazing
[Applause]
look at that and then we
just put it with the base that kelsey
showed you earlier and
oh my gosh this lamp's got a facelift
these look super chic super expensive
honestly around what price point do you
think you could genuinely do this for so
assuming
you already have this lamp all you need
to buy is the paper and the paint which
i think could cost you less than ten
dollars to do
okay i love this you guys i really want
to do this with you again will you
please come back
and we can diy ourselves silly
okay thank you kelsey and becky and be
sure
to check out the surrey girls on youtube
for
even more fun diys
you